bilan de la première tous les avis sont
unanimes y avait du bon et du moins bon
marquez avait quand même plus de moi un
bond de bon hein
enfin tout le monde est d'accord à la
télévision pour se faire une idée faut
attendre la deuxième ou la troisième
quand même la quatrième ou la cinquième
des fois la sixième ou la septième
fournier tu vois également rappelé les
ambitions de cette émission
ce sont celles du service public faire
de la qualité sans oublier l'audience
sans négliger la qualité tout en faisant
de l'audience c'est très clair n'est ce
pas le content d'être revenu en deuxième
semaine
ah bah oui on aime ça on est très
content c'est vrai pour nous et ça ça
nous fait une sortie enfin bon c'est
surtout pour vous parce que quand on a
vu quand même les résultats de la
semaine dernière la personne qui nous a
montré les ce qu'est ce qui a marché ce
qui n'a pas marché bombe à cesser c'est
exactement ce qu'on vous a bein oui oui
et quand l'essentiel vous êtes là à main
quand vous a dit ça on aime bien aimée
avec téléspectateurs ils ont aimé aussi
piquante vous à dire on dit pareil comme
ça ça prouve bien qu avec ma femme on
est pile dans dont la sensibilité du
public arrête donc si vous avez envie
que ça marche pas il faut nous écoute et
on viendrait peut-être lé deuxième
semaine dans tous les quartiers je vois
que le dispositif était au point
oui les animateurs entre le marteau de
la direction et l'enclume des
téléspectateurs je reconnais vraiment et
puis vous allez tirer puisque nos
téléspectateurs moyens parler des
résultats de la semaine dernière on et
faire un petit bilan avec un premier
constat la séquence qui a le mieux
marché la semaine dernière c'est le clip
de michael jackson vous aviez programmé
avec un résultat formidable notamment
sur les 15 17 ans en bretagne et sur
les 13 21 ans dans le roussillon et là
je dois rendre hommage à votre flair et
aux grands professionnels vraiment
michael jackson il fallait y penser j'en
suis comme deux ronds de flan vous avez
oui enfin c'est pas si difficile là vous
mettez le doigt sur le secret des grands
programmateur de télévision les
qu'ancien les brière les gens qui
connaissent très bien leur métier
- c'est tout ça que j'avais remarqué que
michael jackson avait vendu à peu près
450 millions d'albums qu'il était
deuxième au top 50 et un soir j'étais au
restaurant avec ma femme et je lui ai
dit michael jackson on va programmer
nike l jackson et ça a marché
est ce qu'on pourrait faire un petit
bilan de l'est naturellement thierry
c'est la tradition et c'est prévu
ce petit bilan est là je dois une
nouvelle fois vous tirer mon chapeau
vous m'en bouche et un point la séquence
terry qui a fait le meilleur score la
semaine dernière c'est celle de michael
jackson dans thriller
[Applaudissements]
c'est un candidat vous aviez le choix
entre nicole croisille où michael
jackson est là avec un flair incroyable
avec un pif désormais légendaire vous
avez choisi michael jackson s'est on
peut dire vraiment vous avez mérité
cette fameuse médaille de grand pif du
paf qui vous avait été décerné la
semaine dernière parce qu'autant les 7
d'or dont tout le monde sait bien que
c'est truqué en faveur du service public
ça vaut rien et le grand pic du pape
thierry vous l'avez vraiment mérité mais
si on le regardait sans talent se
remplissent de paris je me meurs de vous
remettre au nom du peuple français
le pif du paf merci pour la bonne idée
que vous avez eue la semaine dernière
mulroney une fois merci
bref les i
parce qu'un peu nous à moi c'est la
télévision deux gazettes et oui sommet
[Applaudissements]
on savait ce qui est désolant mairie
savez ce qui est désolant c'est que d'un
côté avec ce genre de trouvaille vous
nous fait gagner de l'audience
et puis de l'autre va vous allez faire
le zozo place de la concorde et qui
pleurnichent gagner ce n'est pas un bon
calcul
le bilan de la semaine dernière mais oui
thierry en effet le bilan c'est
maintenant de tradition dans l'art
d'imagés bien la séquence qui a fait le
meilleur score la semaine dernière c'est
janet jackson c'était votre idée et la
tyrie en trois émissions trois idées
géniales vous est ce qu'on appelle un
magicien de la télévision
malheureusement cette fois ci ce soir
tout magicien que vous êtes j'ai bien
peur que vous ne puissiez plus trouver
une idée du même tonneau
détrompez-vous professeur au je me suis
dit n'y aurait-il pas un jackson blanc
parce que vous savez que michael jackson
se donne beaucoup de mal pour être blanc
celui-là et blanc inouïe ouais et
comment vous est venue cette idée
géniale thierry et si je peux me
permettre de vous le demander
j'étais au restaurant avec ma femme
j'étais un peu pompette pompe est
exactement way et vous mangiez koala des
côtelettes d'agneau professeurs et puis
soudain l'idée venue et je me suis vite
un jackson blanc
oui il ya thierry comme il est
maintenant de tradition dans cette
émission un petit bilan de la semaine
dernière la séquence qui a réalisé le
meilleur score la semaine dernière c'est
le clip de joe jackson ce qui était
votre idée et l'attiré coup de chapeau
en quatre émissions quatre idées
géniales vous est ce qu'on appelle un
magicien de la télévision
[Applaudissements]
maintenant
je crains que tout magicien d'oz est
cette fois-ci vous ne puissiez plus
trouver une idée du même tonneau
détrompez-vous professeur j'ai trouvé
jermaine jackson le frère de michael
jackson et oui thierry mais comment vous
est venue cette idée géniale là j'étais
au restaurant avec ma femme et ma femme
un frère ils n'échouent chier quoi sans
un discrédit côtelettes d'agneau
professeurs
et j'ai pensé vous avez associés et sur
les frères des frères frères
bouleversant 1 et j'ai pensé à jermaine
jackson bien faire et comme il est
maintenant de tradition un petit bilan
de la semaine dernière alors la séquence
qui a le mieux marché la semaine
dernière c'est le clip de jermaine
jackson et ça c'était votre idée alors
thierry vraiment en cinq émissions cinq
idées géniales
vous êtes vraiment ce qu'on appelle un
magicien de la télévision là maintenant
cette semaine tout magicien que vous
êtes je crains que vous ne parveniez
plus la trouver une unité du même
tonneau
détrompez-vous professeur j'ai trouvé
jet alors professeur et bien à thierry
comme il est désormais de tradition un
petit bilan de la semaine dernière la
séquence qui a le mieux marché et la
semaine dernière c'était la séquence
jesse jackson et ça c'était votre idée
et la tuerie vraiment en six émissions 6
idée géniale vraiment on peut dire que
vous êtes ce qu'on appelle un magicien
de la télévision mais cette semaine tout
magicien que vous êtes j'ai bien peur
que vous ne parveniez pas à trouver une
idée
du même tonneau détrompez-vous
professeur âgée troupes et j'ai trouvé
j'ai trouvé là je me suis dit est-ce que
janet jackson n'aurait pas bon thierry
mais comment vous est venue cette idée
géniale
j'étais au restaurant avec ma femme et
un seul coup en regardant ma femme d'un
pasteur mec a un frère je me suis dit
c'est janet jackson n'aurait pas eu
c'est comme ça que j'ai trouvé qu'il
vous mangiez quoi ces indiscrétions des
4 et agneaux prometteur 10 restants
génial
[Applaudissements]
eh bien cher thierry un petit bilan
comme il est de tradition alors la
séquence qui a le mieux marché la
semaine dernière c'était la séquence la
toya jackson et ça c'était votre idée
thiriez l'a vraiment en cette émission
cette idée géniale
vraiment on peut dire que vous êtes ce
qu'on appelle un magicien de la
télévision ça méritait bien ces quelques
applaudissements mais bon là cette
semaine thierry tout magicien que vous
êtes j'ai bien peur que vous ne
parveniez plus à trouver une idée du
même tonneau
détrompez-vous professeur j'ai trouvé
allons rebbie jackson la soeur aînée de
michael jackson alors lalabé comment
vous est venue cette idée géniale tirer
j'étais au restaurant que ma femme
professeur et vous mangiez quoi sans
indiscrétion vont enchaîner avec le
petit bilan qui est désormais de
tradition dans cette émission
la séquence qui a le mieux marché la
semaine dernière c'était la séquence
consacrée à ready jackson et sa thierry
c'était votre idée est là vraiment en
huit semaines 8 idée géniale réellement
on peut dire que vous êtes ce qu'on
appelle un magicien de la télévision ça
valait bien ces quelques
applaudissements et puis en même temps
cette semaine tout magicien que vous
êtes airs et j'ai bien peur que vous ne
parveniez plus à trouver une idée du
même tonneau
détrompez-vous professeur j'ai trouvé
allons les chapeaux jackson chapeau
belge
j'ai calmé excusez moi thierry frézard
discret mais comment vous est venue
cette idée géniale je te restera avec ma
femme mais le
et vous manger quoi sans ajustement
fumée professeur en chantier rivaux
l'émission qui commence dans la joie la
bonne humeur et la franche poilades
posément mais alain les jeunes comme il
est désormais de tradition je vous
propose un petit bilan de la semaine
passée la séquence qui a le mieux marché
la semaine dernière c'était la séquence
consacrée au chapeau jackson et saint
cyrice était votre idée est là vraiment
vous applaudissez pas ça méritait bien
ces quelques applaudissements
extrêmement spontanée et tiens je vous
disais réellement en neuf semaines neuf
idées géniales
honnêtement on peut dire que vous êtes
ce qu'on appelle un magicien de la
télévision
[Applaudissements]
été bien fait quelques applaudissements
très spontané et puis en même temps
cette semaine en 10e semaine 1
j'ai bien peur que tout magicien que
vous êtes vous ne parveniez +1 a trouvé
une idée du même tonneau
détrompez-vous professeur j'ai trouvé ah
ouais on écoute alors attendez c'est là
moi veut ni un phil jackson
extraordinaire jackson comment vous est
venue cette idée géniale
thierry bas j'étais au restaurant avec
ma femme et d'un seul coup je me suis
dit et de serveurs s'appelait philippe
vous mangiez quoi sans indiscrétion j'ai
mangé des côtelettes d'être nouveaux
professeurs et pour être sûr de ne rien
rater de dinars 10 tubes abonnez vous je
m'étais un peu ce bleu